how's it going everybody it's Warren and
yesterday was the official launch of
Disney Plus and as some of you probably
saw there was just a ton of new Marvel
content released many different deleted
scenes for Avengers in game and a new
video from Marvel called Marvel Studios
expanding the universe you may have
caught my video on it yesterday before
it was taken down from YouTube but if
you didn't over the next couple of days
I'll be going over different parts of
the video and today we're going to start
with the Loki teaser that they gave us
there's a lot to go over with what they
gave us in expanding the universe
including some big plot details about
what the show is really going to be
about and how it's going to tie into
other series there's also some things
that Tom Hiddleston has recently said in
some interviews as well so I'll be sure
to cover that in this video of course
and if you're new to my channel and you
love Marvel content be sure to subscribe
I post Marvel content daily and I'm also
doing an Xbox one and ps4 giveaway right
now all you have to do to enter is be
subscribed to my channel with the
notifications turned on leave a like and
drop a comment down below now I would
love to post the full video of this
teaser but as you saw yesterday Disney
copyright claims of my video which they
will do again today if I post it so
we're just gonna go frame-by-frame while
breaking this thing down so this teaser
starts off with a ominous green light
flashing in the background the light
fades in and out which causes the screen
to fade in and now and around it we can
see all of these letters that are
floating around this green light now the
letters around it are all L Zoe's K's
and eyes of course Loki now as this
green light is flashing in and out and
we see the letters for Loki surrounding
it we can hear this sort of ominous
mysterious music playing in the
background and it almost sounds like
something that you would hear in
Sherlock Holmes and Harry Potter which
kind of makes sense because Harry Potter
has to do with wizards and that's
essentially what Loki is he's a sorcerer
but he's also the god of mischief and
he's mysterious which kind of fits for
Sherlock Holmes and Harry Potter so the
camera ends up moving around until
eventually the letters formed the word
Loki of course and then we hear the
words of Marvel Studios President Kevin
Feige and he says another unbelievably
exciting thing that we're getting able
to do is to do a live-action series with
a character that I think you know who
has been one of the most popular
characters in the MCU for years Loki is
coming to Disney Plus and then right
after he says this at
a picture of Tom Holland as Loki smiling
and then he says what have I to fear and
from here it goes into a montage and we
learn a lot about the plot of the series
the first thing that we hear is from
director of the series Kate heron who
says we are taking Loki to a new part of
the MCU we love this character as much
as you guys do and we can't wait to
spend six hours with him so right now as
it stands there are going to be six
episodes all one hour long however
recent findings lead us to believe that
Loki is actually going to get renewed
for a second season and possibly even
more seasons but this makes perfect
sense like Kevin Feige said Loki has
been in the MCU for an extremely long
time and he's a character that everybody
just absolutely loves and if we continue
to listen to what the executive
producers say this series is going to be
absolutely fantastic and they're gonna
want more than one season then executive
producer Stephen Broussard gets on and
he says there's a huge time-travel
component to it there will be a man on
the run quality to it and we get the
chance to explore more human sides of
Loki now the time-travel component to it
I think is something that we all pretty
much expected it's been revealed before
that the show was going to show Loki
kind of jumping through multiple points
in time going to major historical events
and showing us how he kind of effects
them now this is obviously going to take
place in an alternate reality a separate
timeline from the main MCU because an
Avengers in game when he escaped with
the tesseract that in turn created a new
timeline which is something that he was
not supposed to do
The Avengers weren't supposed to let any
nasty timelines get created as they
traveled back through time so an
executive producer Steven Broussard
talks about a man on the run quality to
it they're most likely talking about
Doctor Strange trying to chase Loki down
and fix his timeline because we know
Doctor Strange is in the multiverse of
madness and the reason that the
multiverse is in madness is because
there have been so many alternate
realities created from the events of
Avengers in game I'm sure the Scarlet
Witch will play a major part in
different realities as well but in
Avengers in game we learned that it's
the sorcerer a Supremes job to protect
reality and of course that is dr.
Strange's job now and after avengers
endgame a bunch of different alternate
realities were created so it was his job
to go and fix them which means if he
wants to fix the alternate reality
that loki created he's going to have to
hunt him down so that's probably the man
on the run quality that he was talking
about also not to mention he's going to
be changing main events throughout
history probably of Earth and Asgard and
who knows where else so he'll probably
make some enemies along the way not to
mention in this reality if Thanos is
probably going to be looking for him as
well because Loki just failed Thanos
Thanos gave Loki the sceptre and he lost
it however Thanos is looking for the
Infinity stones and Loki now has the
space stone so it seems like he's going
to be running from Thanos and his army
as well which means we haven't seen the
last of Thanos because he'll probably
make an appearance in the Loki series
especially because we then hear Kevin
Wright who is a supervising producer on
the show say we're finally going to see
Loki on his back foot this is him being
put in a position where he doesn't have
all the answers and has been thrown a
curveball by life and of course that
comes from the events that happened in
Avengers in game when they went back in
time to 2012 and then Michael Waldron
the head writer and executive producer
for the series says that it's going to
explore the questions that we all have
like what happened to Loki where did he
go after Avengers in game and then we
hear Kevin Feige say he goes to a number
of places but he doesn't want to spoil
them and then we hear from Tom
Hiddleston himself and he says this is
one of the most exciting and creative
things that he's had the opportunity to
do and based off of everything that we
just heard in this teaser for Loki it is
going to be insanely creative and in a
recent interview Tom Hiddleston was
asked the big question did Loki really
die in Avengers infinity war because
remember he's the master of illusion
he's the god of mischief Thor even said
in Avengers infinity war he's died
before but I think he's really dead this
time but is he in a recent interview
when Tom Hiddleston was on The Late Show
with Stephen Colbert he confirmed that
the Loki series is indeed going to
answer this question on the show Tom
Hiddleston said in the years since
Avengers infinity war and Avengers in
Game two questions I've been asked is
Loki really dead and what is Loki doing
with that cube it's always the cubes
this series will answer both of the
questions so do me a favor right now
comment down below on whether or not you
think Loki is still alive or if he's
actually dead I
definitely think that he's still alive
but Tom Hiddleston was also in another
interview recently with MTV News where
he told us a little bit more about the
story as well and in this interview he
said so you have his very specific gifts
his intelligence his treachery his
mischief his magic and then seeing him
go up against more formidable opponents
the likes of which he has never seen or
known so in the interview Tom Hiddleston
says that in the Loki series were going
to see him go up against more formidable
opponents the likes of which he has
never seen before and this is extremely
interesting because if we think about it
we have seen him go up against some
really powerful villains he went up
against hella in thor ragnarok who even
his brother thor couldn't kill and of
course he went up against Thanos and
Avengers infinity war whom ended up
killing him or at least that remains to
be seen
but we do know that this alternate
timeline version of Loki is eventually
going to make his way back into the main
MCU timeline we know that the Loki
series is going to directly set up some
of the events that take place in Thor
for love and thunder including Loki
jumping back to the main MCU timeline
and bringing with him a version of Mele
near this is supposedly how Jane Foster
gets Millner and transforms into Jane
Foster Thor and this is rather
interesting as well because Mueller
typically has a worthiness enchantment
on it so unless Loki visited an
alternate reality in which Mueller did
not have a worthiness enchantment on it
Loki is now worthy enough to pick up
Mueller so we are going to see just a
total transformation from Loki in this
series because again the 2012 Loki that
escapes with the tesseract is a
completely different Loki than we see in
the beginning of infinity war so we're
definitely going to see Loki do a major
transformation over the course of this
series and then it has been officially
confirmed that Loki is going to tie in
to Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness and this was confirmed just a
few days ago by Disney CEO Bob Iger and
Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige and
again there's really two ways that Loki
could tie into multiverse of madness one
way of course is what I mentioned before
Doctor Strange is going to try to fix
all of the alternate timelines that were
created during avengers endgame this
means that Doctor Strange is going to
have to hunt Loki because Loki is going
to be jumping throughout different
points in time and every time he jumps
to a different point in time he's going
to create an alternate reality with
whatever actions he does and since they
just revealed to us yesterday that Loki
is going to have a man on the run kind
of concept to it this makes a lot of
sense another thing is that Wanda the
Scarlet Witch actually kind of has some
similar powers to Loki now Loki is a
sorcerer and he knows magic and the
Scarlet Witch got her powers from the
mine stone but their powers aren't that
different so there's always a connection
that could be made between the two of
those characters but whatever that
connection is it sounds like the Loki
series is going to be absolutely amazing
and is going to be a major very
important part of the future of the MCU
so we got a lot of plot details from
this teaser that Disney released
yesterday with Marvel Studios expanding
the universe on Disney Plus let me know
what you think about this let me know
down below how excited you are to
finally see the Loki series when it
comes out and again don't forget to
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date with MCU and so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 if you enjoyed the video please
give it a thumbs up and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof